let's have a garden ease now I'm putting
this question up on the board in full
knowledge that a good number of you or
I'm hoping will have gotten to this this
morning so this is question section this
one of these exercise can I have a show
of hands who's at least started on these
questions hand up straight and keep your
head up if you finish them as well I
could get hands down so well done to you
guys what I would advise you to do if
you had your hand up right at the end
there and have done these then you're
welcome to continue working through but
when I'm done here when I start talking
just look up and have a look at the way
I've set things out just to make sure it
lines up with the way you've done things
as well okay so for the majority of
people who have either started on these
or I haven't even gotten to these yet
let's have a look I've a metaphor in my
mind for you into which all these
questions kind of fit I think of these
questions here
kind of like printer you're the Lego
except you only have two pieces to
choose from and these are your two
pieces okay
from these two pieces you can build
every other thing that you're going to
be asked to work with here and what I
like about this and what I love about
Lego is that you can know these two
pieces very well but it requires some
creativity and imagination to get to
whatever read concoction it is that we
give you which you know you have to get
through some twists and turns before you
get to them okay so let's have a start
just by having a look at this quadratic
and working out the sum and their
product of the roots based on the
coefficients when we begin how it
advised that the first thing you write
down is just the result that's just to
help you remember and so that when you
go and do the substitution you get it
right in this case what is minus B on a
come on have a look at the numbers 5 on
2 cool
there's building block number one and
building block number two the product
again I'll write that down
that's fine I'll write this down just so
that I can help myself remember the
result in this case CoA is cool not
complicated okay
now how do I use these things to get to
all of these well alpha minus 1 beta
minus 1 there's actually two ways to go
about this but the simplest way is just
to expand the thing and see how when you
brought this out you've got the building
blocks just sitting there
okay so alpha minus 1 beta minus 1 if
you just pair up your terms it looks
like you're going to get alpha beta
minus alpha minus beta plus 1 how does
that look okay with that expansion
thumbs up and so you can see here it
didn't take very much work I could do
one more thing just to make it super
obvious this is taking out the factor of
negative 1 and so you can see I know
what this is and I know what this is so
I'm just going to do a straight
substitution to evaluate this
so alpha beta was 1/2 take away 5 on 2
plus 1 what is that
I think 1/2 minus 2 and 1/2 is minus 2
and then plus 1 is negative 1 are you
happy with that so excuse me you can
evaluate that I'm not even really
worried about it it's these pieces and
then moving them around and seeing where
inside the expression the pieces that
I'm familiar with are hiding that's what
I'm really interested in ok let's have a
look at D now after the negative 1 is
just a fancy way of writing 1 and alpha
same deal with the beta so when you have
a look at this again thankfully doing
the thing that we normally do with
fractions just like the thing that we
normally do with terms like this it
expand is going to give us the results
if I put these two fractions on a common
denominator like I do all the time when
I'm adding fractions what is that common
denominator alpha beer
okay which is familiar and then when you
have a look at how these are gonna have
to be changed you multiply this one by
Peter on beta so that gives you this you
multiply this one by alpha and alpha
which gives you that okay and lo and
behold the two results that you already
know so what do we got here five on two
on one on two and of course that's just
five okay that's not too complicated
again if you just sort of combine terms
often the correct use of the pieces just
falls out but then sometimes you get two
ones like this and you know there's no
obvious thing to do with this it's kind
of as simple as it gets
there's no factorization so there's kind
of a bit of a trick here that requires a
bit creativity to work out any
suggestions yeah okay so let's just
rewind a second Cheyennes first
suggestion was to think about this guy
now before we have a think about him I
want you to understand why this makes
sense because you're being asked to have
squares of roots and these things don't
have any squares in them so something's
gonna have to be squared however when
you go ahead and you give this a go you
find this is not what you wanted right
that's not what we were asked to create
it's got extra things what's the extra
two alpha beta but that extra we can get
rid of because we know what alpha and
beta are okay so the way that I would
write this is back to my top line now
this red stuff was like sort of working
on the side I would write that this is
equal to alpha plus beta all squared
take away that extra stuff because I
don't actually want the extra stuff like
so okay and you can see now I know what
pieces go into this I can simply
substitute in what did I just say five
onto or squared take away what just one
so it's gonna be 21 on four okay again
the number is not the important part the
manipulation in the rearrangement are
now then you come to this last one put
your pins down because even those of you
who said oh I did question six this is
fine
you might notice by the star this is not
in question six so I'm just going to
throw this one at you this one is
different to the others in at least a
couple of different ways they all want
to suggest before we get to an answer
how is this one different what's a way
in which this question is different to
the previous form we just did
there's no beta and that's kind of um
that's kind of a signal to you that oh
this is gonna be a little bit different
from the others okay
there's no beta so no matter what way
you combine these guys you actually it
can never get rid of beta it's always
sort of sticky around there okay so
therefore your alpha beta and your alpha
beta I'm going to be on their own enough
what else is different about this
anything else that's weird unusual hmm
so interesting traces of numbers they're
two and negative five those anywhere
else on the board that you can see there
in the original question aren't they
they're they're right up here now what
this question is about is not so much
some product of roots but the roots
themselves and whether you understand
what it means for something to be a root
so if I think about something like my
good Old Faithful here okay we know what
the roots of this equation are well you
know what they are you know what the two
numbers are cuz this is like the ten
thousandth time I showed you this
equation think about what happens with
those roots and what makes them roots
for instance one is not a root of this
equation why not
I like the number one why isn't under
root
let me let me made phrase the question
in the rest you've got two numbers in
your mind right that are the roots
what's so special about them that makes
them the roots of this equation yeah
okay so when x equals 1 I would get 1
plus 5 plus 6 which is 12 right but put
12 not what it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be 0 whereas well tell me
one of the other words that you have in
your mind the actual roots net negative
3 new you three so that would give you 9
minus 15 plus 6
aha so it's a root because it makes this
statement true do you agree so if alpha
and beta are the roots of this equation
then if for example you put alpha into
here what would you get if you put alpha
into this left-hand side what should you
get you should get 0 just like we did
over there right so therefore I can
infer this is the way that I would write
it I would say since alpha is a root
what did I just say plus 1 right since
it's a root what it means to be a root
is it satisfies this equation does that
make sense
so therefore 2 alpha squared minus 5
alpha plus 1 is 0 are you okay do you
see how this just gets that well that's
that's the definition of what a root is
right so now can you tell me what 2
alpha squared minus 5 alpha is 2 alpha
squared minus 5 alpha if you want that
to be the subject of the equation what
do you do you just subtract 1 from both
sides wouldn't you so it's negative 1
okay
excuse me so that's a bit stinky what my
point is here is even though a lot of
this is about manipulation you don't
even need to someone doesn't even know
at least no alpha and beta are equal
like what they mean in order to do a lot
of this you do need to know what alpha
beta mean in order to really get the
heart of what this subject is doing okay